all right Christina Christina where'd
you grow up were you from Riverside
Riverside California and tell me about
your family hit both your parents nah I
wasn't I wasn't my mom used to smoke
crack though she still does actually
she's still right here I know she gave
me a system when I was like two months
old I got adopted and my god family
decided to give me up as well and so I
was really just jumping around a foster
home to foster home like throughout my
life how was your childhood sounds
pretty rough then I really have one
honestly I had to grow too fast
my mom didn't have any money for the
bills nothing so it was like you know I
would go out so drugs just some [ __ ]
you know sorry gave me need some more
dumb [ __ ] getting caught up for them she
doesn't even do what age were you on
streets you join you join a gang yeah
which gang a mess
it's ms-13 yeah
Mexican gang nice table three game oh
sorry
never really liked see guys repetition
huh and they're using drugs yeah sure
meth
how long have you use down since Oslo
and yet you're working as a prostitute
is wrong right once in a while
how can you do that whenever the money
did
how do you know what 16 you're 16
are you going to high school no why'd
you drop out
I never made like rated you finished
eight instead of going to school you
just been what do you do for money now
so drugs and prostitute
you have any contact with your with your
family
nah don't talk to me don't speak with me
at all
you've been arrested gang a time Kobe
what kind of stuff did get you arrested
um 211 [ __ ] breaking entering um
breaking entering into private property
stuff like that I saw so dizzy weapon oh
[ __ ]
I feel that I have a wire you gotta do
the whole world in 32 please you're
gonna listen
Oh God well that's great look yeah so
where do you see your life going from
here you're 16
I'm gonna be dead how would you die
youth most likely you think what's the
most dangerous thing what's likely way
that you would die Wow
just the gang violence and the guns and
all it it's my hood or my pen give him
something that he keeps your money no I
wish you would
nah yeah it's pretty [ __ ] up you know
everybody here knows me where do you
live now everywhere
but you like are you homeless sir yeah
you are so you stay on the street and
it's kid row or somewhere else
everyone just wherever whatever the
money that but what neighborhood you
normally hang out in East LA somewhere
yeah story you know everybody out here
excuse me and people think I'm fine you
know people don't know what people like
me go through it kind of sucks what do
you think people don't understand just
trouble it's hard to be here by yourself
but nobody to trust nobody go to your
family I've called my parents movies I'm
gonna pay him to go home interesting
nobody cares on nobody here I'll hear
it's all dog-eat-dog world people think
that when they have a job and [ __ ] that
they have it good you know they think
that they're [ __ ] struggling that
they're [ __ ] going through it or
whatever they're not going to [ __ ] there
are no words like to [ __ ] eat house
trash or to plug in now I've [ __ ]
clothes to wear or shoes that fit you
they don't know what it's like to be
afraid for tomorrow
there know what it's like that they do
something you don't want to do just to
survive and this is a [ __ ] that I go
through on a daily basis you know what's
the worst thing you've seen all right
see my best friend get a haircut off for
what because she didn't want beer
I've seen them bringing girls younger
than me like I just [ __ ] him up like bad
nice I just kill him no one's ever gonna
know what they're at what they did
nothing
these are gang-related incidents or
hates the street street stuff what about
your childhood could have been different
it might have spared you from this
situation maybe if my family would have
actually given a [ __ ] a little bit more
and maybe I would have been different
was your dad ever in the picture yeah
but my dad was the [ __ ]
Blaine was here in your life for sure
Wow
so would you say your dad if he could
speak talk [ __ ] you [ __ ] you cuz he was
one that maybe his way
give me dreams or goals or anything and
you you'd like to see happen in your
future you're still very young I want to
just be happy bro the only dream I
probably got is just to be happy cuz
just because I smile every day just
because I walk around like I'm cool I'm
not happy
listen does okay me looking at look at
myself in the mirror without feeling
like yeah this is what life is you
depress a lot yeah I don't show it
because if you show it then it's a sign
of weakness when you're weak is when the
people brown you the most I just learn
how to write fake make sure that
everyone thinks I'm cool
you're close friends nah there are no
friends out here sometimes and I look
around us he's animals worse than
animals actually maggots cuz animals
don't even do what we do sometimes
you'll find yourself in a relationships
where the only reason you're sticking
around is because I think it gives you
food or a place to stay you know but
he'll beat the [ __ ] out of you every day
but [ __ ] he's feeding you clothing you
give you somewhere to stay if you leave
you be ungrateful will we help you the
most right now escape sometimes I wish I
could just pack my [ __ ] away you know
we're on our way to where everythings is
everywhere I go is the same thing
no one's ever gonna be able to
understand the trials and she really
does not come with me on the streets
the streets will take your soul and eat
it up and you'll never be able to get
away
it's crazy because it's like people
think that just because I'm young and
I'm a girl and I'm pretty supposedly
that they can just take advantage of
whatever the [ __ ] it is that I have
nobody ever really knows what's up with
anything I used to be a cutter Brooks he
I was younger and then one day I was in
MacArthur Park and there was these dudes
I wanted to [ __ ] I told no I'm cool
I woke up at 3:00 in the morning with I
was laying on my stomach and one of them
was on top of me I'm a back they sliced
my neck open bro I said open oh well and
they cut it with white oh nice machete
and then they all round you know
these streets will take something
beautiful and there's like crush it and
just like make sure that that's just
nothingness because out here there's
just one thing money talks [ __ ]
walks
you can pay somebody to do anything out
here bro and they'll do it
if it's the price is right you know I
got kidnapped from Riverside kidnap got
take it over here I saw my best friend
get her head cut off and I ran she died
basically so I could run you know use
the mother girl ended up over in the
park and then I went to over a street
sorry selling dope smoking dope I met
this a guy named Chuck huh my baby's dad
he used to make me prostitute myself or
else I was that alright he told me
basically if you don't sell your [ __ ]
mckee and so for a long time I was doing
that with the fear of if I don't do this
in my die and then one day I decided to
run away when I ran away I never went
back you know after that I started
getting some [ __ ] up relationships
abusive relationships and every time I
would meet somebody that that wasn't
help they just ended up [ __ ] me over
you know when I had my daughter I
thought my family was gonna let me go
back home I call my mom and I told her
like mom like I'm like I had a baby they
can't please go back home I'm gonna be
out here she told me that sounds like a
personal problem she hung up on me
so everything I ever thought was right
isn't really right out here is wrong
whatever thought was wrong is right what
is isn't what isn't is
I think children old people get killed
just didn't want to comply with what the
[ __ ] these people want I've been raped
so many times that can count on one hand
my grandmother died I couldn't go to the
funeral my father died I could go to
school yet I still find a reason to
smile every day you know I've been
kidnapped before at gunpoint I've been
robbed I've been stabbed
it sucks cuz nobody will ever know what
a person like me goes to her databases
or give a [ __ ] really obviously I wanted
a store I see people to have a life to
have somewhere to go have somewhere to
be they look at me with disgust and I
just think to myself like damn I wonder
how they wouldn't give me if they knew
what I've been through you know
I'm the reason I'm doing this because I
hope that maybe somebody who gives a
[ __ ] was it and somebody who gives a
[ __ ] will try and help that's what I'm
hoping for
Christina thank you so much for talking
with me hmm
you